what's happening with Tick Tock
indoctrinating our youth we've talked
about this before if you look at Tick
Tock in China it's all things to educate
the youth math science Humanities
whatever they're allowed to show in
China whereas here it's just nonsense
dances you know Clorox bleach challenges
on steroids and I think you know Tick
Tock has already been banned in what
India a couple couple countries major
countries yeah a lot of
um countries in the EU banned it from
government I think the United States is
actually already banned it from
government phones government buildings
Wi-Fi buildings exactly right you know
um this essentially is a trojan horse
for China to indoctrinate American Youth